hi my name is Brian Molina I am a former
Apple store employee hi my name is David
I am a former Apple employee hi my name
is glory I'm a current Apple store
employee and today we're going to be
answering your question what is it like
at the store on the day that a new
iPhone is released well this past
September was my first launch and it was
insane there's lines outside all day the
store is always busy but somehow there
was even more people inside the store
it's just basically organized chaos my
first year it was packed it was pretty
crazy there's a lot of hype going into
it and since this launch was three
iPhones
and the watch it was a whole lot going
on in the store but yeah the hype lasts
for about two weeks of craziness do
people still wait outside overnight to
get the new iPhone yes people should do
that which sometimes confuses me so you
like drive into parking to work and you
just see this line of people like in
their little chairs in tents it's not
that serious just go online and buy it
for the iPhone I've seen them there a
day or two before but also for the iPad
iPod they would come just a few hours
before we would open the stores and just
kind of wait there what was the worst a
most annoying problem to deal with we
would have this setup area where after
you purchase you would go there and they
would help you set up the phones help
you set up the computers and sometimes
even myself I used to be there for four
five six hours with one customer
especially if someone doesn't know like
the PIN number to an account or they
don't know like the password it's always
like password related things just people
know your passwords write them down for
me personally it's when people come in
to the Apple Store and ask questions
about their Gmail accounts those really
get to me because it's like I don't work
for Google don't really know how to help
you with the situation so that's
probably the most annoying problem to do
with can you get banned from the Apple
Store um not really if they were like
trouble customers and then we always
keep an eye out for them and
know if in the future they came in to
kind of just keep an eye out for them
it's not like pictures of people on the
walls somewhere that says this person
cannot be in here it was more so just
get out stuff like that but not to the
degree where you're actually banned can
you get kicked out for staying and using
the products for too long no you
definitely can
you can sit inside the store and use the
computers or iPads or phones from open
to close as long as you aren't bothering
anyone although when it gets really busy
then yes because people are trying to
like test everything out and you only
have so many like I'm actually whatever
but it's usually like 4 hours or so is
the longest that I've seen or sometimes
we had this one guy that would come in
basically do his work at our job people
knew him when he would have come in all
he just works like he comes and works in
here some way okay that's that's cool if
you're good with that I'm good with that
how easy is it for an employee to tell
if a customer's product is fake mm
depending on where it got it from it
could be pretty hard to tow I think the
the most popular thing to try and fake
was like a screen like a third party
screen when the geniuses are messing
with the phone and they can tell the
screws are different sometimes the home
when there was a home button the home
button will be a little loose and toggle
II and then you'd be able to tell that
things are moved and shifted I could
never really tell but there was when
there was someone replaced when I'd like
to display iPhones with a cookie and
that I could tell that I was fake for
sure but the icing was very clean and
it's very well done is every employee at
the Apple Store own an iPhone no not
everybody has an iPhone and that's fine
like we don't shame I mean they're worse
people shave them some people don't like
the iPhones like we don't know how to
work it that you know to eat its own has
anyone ever attempted to steal one of
the products on display yes absolutely
it's too many times you see people who
like put the beats on just like kind of
walk out you see people who just grab
accessories people love to like take off
their case and then like replace it with
one of the sample cases I've seen people
come in and they go to certain table and
then just yank phones off the table and
then run out this happens like once a
week there's been instances where people
will get caught but a lot of people are
very successful with getting away with
it and we're just told not to do
anything
because we're all just like trained to
be like doesn't matter as soon as iPhone
leaves a story because they're all demo
devices they can't do anything with them
is it illegal to jailbreak your iPhone I
don't know if it's illegal but I'm sure
it's like frowned upon like you're not
supposed to do that because if you try
to bring it in to trade it or get a new
one they're not gonna take I'm not gonna
give you anything and then if you go to
the Genius Bar to get your phone fixed
they're not gonna fix it because it's
basically not an Apple product anymore
so I'm gonna go with yes it's illegal
because they're just tampering with all
the internal stuff that goes on with the
phone anyway easy answer is I think yes
it is illegal and are the geniuses
actually smart yeah they would they they
really are honestly they're geniuses I
they do go through a lot of training to
do the things that they do they know a
lot of the techie side of things and
sometimes when I didn't know an answer I
would watch the back and I would ask
them and they would just like that
they'd look in a second they knew was
not the way they were talking about
luckily I think there's a pretty good
culture and Apple that we're all in it
together no matter what our positions
are and there's no like competition
everyone's really nice no one seems like
snobby or like mean because they know
more than I do everyone's pretty helpful
and nice so I hope that answers on you
guys's questions and we do want to help
and we will help otherwise google it and
you'll find out there
[Music]